thank you uh you're so kind i appreciate
that
thank you to coming to my classroom i
see the same faces
every week but we love you for doing
that for us and i'm so excited because
4 20 is
there's only four copying days left
i'm so excited i haven't even started my
baking
but i just know it's gonna be a great
holiday if people if you're
squares at home and you don't know
about 4 20 um
4 20 is the holiday stone it's where you
stay home
from work get stoned all day and eat
junk food
previously known as 2020.
but uh
but hey i'm going to start with some
good news we are finally getting out of
afghanistan that is the big political
news this week
wow no biden
america is not anymore the world's
policeman if we were we'd have shot them
i mean wow this
all the news is shootings police
citizens
another horrible shooting today of eight
people in indianapolis we've had 45 mass
shootings
in the last month and uh in a related
story our long-term
study on the effectiveness of thoughts
and prayers is in
no doesn't work no we studied it
and then this latest atrocity that
happened right in minneapolis while the
trial is going on
and it turns out the guy who was shot
pulled over because he was had an air
freshener
hanging from his rear-view mirror which
apparently is actually an eagle
illegal thing in five states an air
fresher hanging from a mirror because
apparently that's very dangerous
yeah it can lead to getting pulled over
and shot by the cops i
i i mean i'm trying to be fair to the
cops too but come on
fellas ladies but the good news is joe
biden is kicking ass
59 approval rating 72 percent approve of
what he's doing with covet including 55
percent of republicans
a lot of republicans
a lot of republicans are saying boy are
we glad this guy stole the election
but i mean getting out of afghanistan is
a big [ __ ] deal to quote joe himself
big [ __ ] i mean two presidents before
him obama and trump said they would do
it promised to end the war
didn't biden just [ __ ] did it he he
over
he
he overruled the generals he's president
i'm too old for this [ __ ]
but i'm telling you getting out of
afghanistan is not going over well with
everybody did you see lindsey graham oh
he is taking it very hard
lindsay lindsay knows where our boys
should be
no he's he is not happy about his
getting out of afghanistan i saw him on
the talk shows he had that look on his
face he gets
he looks like he got to church and
another lady was wearing the same hat
you know i don't mean another
but come on afghanistan 20 years matt
gates's girlfriends weren't even born
when this war started
it's about time oh more allegations were
there matt gates he's in trouble young
women now
have were talking to cnn this week and
they were talking about the parties
he used to have cocaine ecstasy pill
popping
lots of sex who knew republicans could
party like this
it sounds it sounds like an orgy and you
know republican orgies
are a little different
how so bill well i'll tell you how
if you if you hear somebody saying who's
your daddy
they're trying to verify a ballot
signature that's how
they're different oh you're a great
crowd thank you
uh but matt gates he says he is innocent
of any sexual
impropriety he said it's all a big
misunderstanding he said yes
i pulled out my dick in front of a 17
year old i thought it was a taser
he's just they're shameless these
republicans
oh and sadness in great britain today
this is their burying prince philip you
saw he died last week at 99.
and the queen is already dating hunter
biden
well it makes sense he is a thing for
widows
and she has a thing for bad teeth and
and they're both open to sex with
relatives anyway
are you sitting down because big news
this week the bachelor came out as gay
you didn't see oh this is big stuff i
mean there were clues that uh
colton underwood he said there were
clues because he said on the show he
hadn't dated many women
i said he called himself an accidental
virgin
and then on the last episode when he
when he proposed to liza minnelli
you